think it is that I want to be borders I
think the do that I'll dear just wave a
favor yeah where were we up with a
question you know good on question time
there would have so many waves up me
when it comes to building a profile taxi
drivers Steven picton has taken an
unusual path youtube videos and charity
performances have helped him become well
known in the town
I've got one that face is in town that
everybody knows everybody knows what
I've been doin minds a lot of people
don't recognize me since the weight loss
since he launched his campaign Stevens
become known as the campaigning cabbage
give you one of them cards then if you
have a look on there there's the website
yeah any money fish stores on there I'm
yep I've yeah I'd want to be leaflets to
the diet not there you go you will be
getting them to the door don't you worry
about that let's go fish production so
you're gonna win i think i will ya I
think it'd be brilliant it this town
that one big party if we talk